There is a stunning new poll out of the red
state of Georgia in which Democratic presidential
challenger Joe Biden is winning against Donald
Trump by one point.
This is absolutely and completely insane and
probably not indicative that Biden is going
to win Georgia.
And I want to talk about that in a moment.
There's actually a lot to talk about here.
And this is really going to get us into a
discussion of the role of polling going forward
from now until November 3rd, the last time.
Let's start in Georgia.
The last time that a Democratic presidential
candidate won Georgia was 28 years ago.
Was Bill Clinton in 1992.
It was a squeaker.
Bill Clinton winning by zero point five percent
of the vote over George H.W. Bush.
But notice, if you're watching that there
was a third party candidate, Ross Perot, who
did get 13 percent of the vote in Georgia.
So the last time that a Democrat won Georgia
without a significant third party candidate
was 1980, 40 years ago when Jimmy Carter defeated
Ronald Reagan.
But that was Jimmy Carter's home state.
So the last time.
Stick with me here.
That a Democratic presidential candidate won
Georgia in a two way race when Georgia was
not their home state was nine.
1860, when John F. Kennedy defeated Richard
Nixon brutally, 62 to 37.
That was 60 years ago.
So when we see a poll today that says Biden's
winning by one in Georgia, to me it's a signal
that it could be a bad November for Trump.
It's not really a signal that Biden's going
to win Florida.
The average I'm sorry, Georgia, the average
in Georgia is still Trump winning by one point
six.
But the important thing about the latest CBS
News poll, which has Biden plus one, is that
it's using a likely voter model instead of
a registered voter model.
And I've talked to you before about the importance
of this.
If you just survey adults, that's considered
the least accurate because half the country
doesn't vote.
If you survey registered voters, it is considered
more accurate because you're at least restricting
the poll to people who are registered to vote.
Many registered voters don't vote, but it's
more accurate than just all adults because
many adults just aren't even registered and
they never vote.
Likely voter is arguably, if done correctly,
the most accurate.
And so that's a good thing.
That's a good sign that as we start to see
registered voter models become likely voter
models as we close in on November, the polling
should become more accurate.
That being said, this poll that has Joe Biden
winning by one in Georgia has a three point
four percent margin of error.
So what that means is the poll could actually
be in reality.
Biden is at forty two point six and Trump
is at forty eight point four.
That's what the margin of error means.
So this poll, which has Biden plus one, could
actually be Trump plus six and be within the
margin of error.
So what that means is we should take nothing
from this other than everybody's got to vote.
Whether you think your state will be close
or not, you've got to vote.
I do not believe Trump will win Georgia.
But if enough polls say it's tight, maybe
Trump has to spend money there.
Maybe Trump has to campaign to Georgians.
That's a victory, getting Republicans to have
to spend money in Georgia, in Texas, cetera.
That's a good thing.
So the big picture of this sort of battleground
and moderate rates, red state polling, is
that Trump is now, according to the new polling,
losing by four in North Carolina, losing by
one in Georgia.
There is some Texas polling that has Trump
down.
The meaning of it is this is a really bad
presidency.
That's the takeaway given the hyper polarized
nature of the country right now.
When you look at these traditionally red states
and you see that, it looks like it's close.
That means that there are some partizan right
wingers that are realizing this is so bad
that I'm at least as of right now, not yet
committed to support Donald Trump.
You know, Mago will be Magga.
Trump will still get tens of millions of votes.
That's an indictment of our country, no doubt.
But there is actually some reason that is
injecting itself up, embedding itself in the
brains of some committed right wingers.
But we can't forgive the ignorance.
If our population had been better at critical
thinking and had done 10 minutes of actual
research back in 2016.
Trump never would have been the nominee and
certainly never would have become president
of the United States.
Many of the unnecessary coronavirus deaths
that we've had would not have happened, and
that number is likely to hit 160000 in the
next day or two.
So what we want to do here is understand what's
happening so that it doesn't happen again.
Starting with this November.
But we can't forget how it happened.
We can't ignore that it could happen again
and it still might happen again in November
if we don't vote.
So to go back to Georgia for a moment.
It's not just that there's a margin of error
and Trump might actually be winning like that's
one interpretation would be OK.
Biden's plus one.
But you look at the margin of error, could
really be Trump plus six.
That's that's one part of it.
The other part of it is when you look at the
history of voter suppression in Georgia, when
you look at the planned voter suppression
in Georgia, it should give us zero confidence
that these close states are even going to
have a shot at going our way unless we completely
overwhelm the voting in November.
So it's a sad reality.
There's a lot we're up against right now,
and it includes five or six different ways
in which Donald Trump is going to try to suppress
the vote.
We have to accept that and work with it.
And what that means is so overwhelming voting
turnout and every every election, both sides
say it.
Where are sides motivated?
We're going to have record turnout and very
often, particularly among some voting groups,
it doesn't happen.
We actually have to do that to overwhelm Trump,
kneecapping the post office, voter purges,
limiting vote by mail and on and on and on.
that's the only way forward.